hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round six of the
2018 renegade chess classic I know in my
previous video
Fabiano Caruana versus - I said it was
round five when it was actually round
six but the game is the same but it
doesn't really matter which round it is
so here we have Mathias blue bomb versus
a former world champion Vishwanathan
Anand
and it's a quite an interesting game the
game really takes a weird turn at one
point when Anand starts thinking like an
engine and it this is a very very
peculiar moment but I'll show you what I
mean by this and unfortunately I don't
have any photos of this encounter since
all the photos I have from round six are
mostly of Magnus Carlsen and that's what
happens when you're a world champion and
I know he was a voted like top 10
sexiest man in the world by the UK
Cosmopolitan magazine or something but
you do have to take photos of other
players as well so maybe maybe in the
next round so let's see this game and I
did prepare the final standings so at
least we'll have that mattias opens it
with d4 we'd have d5 c4 e6 Knight to f3
so the Queen's Gambit the client is on
the board and D captures and c4 the
rosenthal variation III and the
immediate b5 so on and for the moment he
decides that he will do that he will try
to defend the c4 pawn and if you you
know if you read any book for openings
any book for beginners on openings and
something it everywhere every book will
tell you do not to defend the c4 form
but at a level at I mean at this level
you can you can even do that so a4
immediately obviously before Bishop
captures on c4 Knight to f6 and now a5
so obviously a very very prepared
variation by both of them a six-night B
to d2 Bishop to b7 and now castles c5 a
c5 definitely a principled move White
has a strong Center black has a backward
c7 pawn makes sense to take those two
into consideration push c5 attack
White's wrong center and get rid of your
backwards pawn Knight to b3 defending
the d4 pawn also pressure
the c5 pawn and 9:37 developing a knight
and also now adding more protection to
the c5 Point D capture son c5 going for
a series of exchanges Knight captures
Knight captures the Bishop captures and
now Queen to a4 check white once the
exchange Queens but he doesn't want to
do it with Queen captures and e8 to
develop the blacks rook so instead Queen
to a4 check Queen blocks now Queen
captures Knight captures and rush to d2
are preparing to develop a and
connecting rooks King to e7 and now rook
a to c1 rook F rook H to c8 protecting
the Bishop on c5 so no discoveries can
be made
Knight to d4 we have Knight to e5 and
here Bishop back to e2 controlling this
knight on e5 Bishop to d6 and now rook F
to D 1 and this is a move 19 and pretty
much the critical moment in the game
here and this is why I say that it's a
moment where on and started thinking
like an engine here you do have to go
for this line Knight to c6 this is this
is essential for black and after this
move
what follows is rook the c4 after Knight
captures you can capture on before
everything is fine for both white and
black this game this game will simply
continue you can't grab the rook if you
grab the rook of course you get Bishop
captures and then it's check you lose
the night here so King it you see you
grab this one and here white is winning
so after this Knight to c6 definitely
would be the best idea but here on and
played Bishop to d5 Bishop to d5 is a
move that engine recommends but only
only in the first like couple of seconds
after then it doesn't think bishop d5 is
is either an option and it seems like
Anand
got to this engine fever and played
Bishop to d5 but it's not really it's
not really clear why it doesn't work but
later it does even I will put a link in
the description below I work and check
out an interview with Matias blue bombed
it and even he thought that this wasn't
really anything he thought that it was a
drawn position so rook captures on c8
rook captures on c8 and now
got résumé six blue bong grabs upon but
now Alan simply plays rook to eight
forces the bishop back and then he will
capture the pawn on e5
so Bishop back to f1 rook captures only
five and here nice the b5 nice to be
five with the idea that if black plays a
silly move or something then Knight
captures on d6 is a threat King captors
and Bishop capture some before check
wins the rook on a5 of course but after
this night would be five move Bishop to
c5 not allowing to capture the bishop on
d6 and here comes the problem the real
problem rook the c1 and here you don't
really you don't really have a good move
for black if you if you don't move the
bishop you're gonna get rook captures
Bishop if you play Bishop back to these
six you're gonna get the same idea as
before Bishop captures and you lose the
ruku to check another thing if you play
what appears to be the best idea
nice to see for now you block the
defense of the night by the bishop on f1
and after Bishop captures Bishop
captures you don't want to capture
because rook will simply capture the
night here so after night to d4
you have to move the bishop as it's
attacked and now comes rogue captures on
c5 rook captures and Bishop captures on
b4 again pinning this rook and after the
King defends it now simply for the
bishop has to be keep protecting the be
three square if you capture Knight to b3
and you lose a whole rook here so Bishop
to a two you have to keep an eye on the
B 3 square now comes f4 and the white
will always be able to grab this rook so
the king the King has the stay there the
King can't move anywhere since the pawns
and the knight ours are controlling the
King so it's a it's a much better
position for white white will capture
this rook whenever he feels like it he
does have his upon up it's a past B
point so an excellent position for white
and this is the problem why there's
really nothing to play here from black
so I don't ride rook to a2 he decided to
give up a piece to grab this B to pawn
and create a past be bone of his own and
blue bomb said that when a nun played
Rock tray to that there was there was so
much confidence in Ireland
while he played this and blue bomb
couldn't really believe that this was
okay for honor
but okay we have rook captures on c5
there's really nothing else this is the
best move on unplaced rook capture some
v2 and now II for attacking the bishop
you can't capture capturing losses
immediately after rook captures on e5
rook captures and rook captures here a
blue bomb would simply be up to pieces
for this passed pawn it's not not at all
enough so after he for rook captures on
b2 pawn captures on on d5 and now he
captures on d5 rook to c1 + b3 now now
on and starts pushing his passport rook
to be one blocking b2 and nights to c3
now regarding b1 square and also
preventing any any ideas of row coming
into the back rank ninth the c4 Knight
captures on d5 rook captures on d5
Bishop captures on c4 attacking the rook
rook to c5 and now rook to e1 check King
f6 and now Bishop to d3 and here you
don't really you don't really have any
compensation for this for being down a
piece I mean it is a past 1 and B 2 but
not nearly enough here rook to d2 was
played rock the c1 doesn't give like
anything it seems like maybe something
but after King f1 black black has
nothing here
so after Bishop to d3 rook to d5
attacking the bishop bishop now goes to
b1 and allowing this point to move
forward and you know what do you do here
is black well the best best thing to do
would be to resign but of course you do
have a passed pawn on b2 so why do it
just immediately g3 g5 King to g2 now
comes g4 kind of pressuring that came to
stay on g2 rock tree to rook to b5 rook
to e8 rook to d5 route back to e2
a couple of repetition moves but now
move 40 has been reached time control is
here and there is really nothing to do
here
rook to b 5h for now King to g7 rook to
e7 r up to d5 rook to b7 attacking the
pawn now rook to d2 defending Bishop to
a2 pressuring the f7 pawn
now comes King to h6 not allowing the
point to be captured with check and now
simply Bishop captures on f7 and it was
in this position that we show not a nun
and resigned the game he resigned
because now there really isn't anything
to do so far you could have you know you
could have kept this King under lock and
key here there's really no way for him
to enter the game but now black doesn't
have a move if you move the rook
anywhere from the second rank then white
will simply capture the b2 pawn and if
you you can't really play any moves with
the King this is covered by the point is
scored by the bishop and if you go g7 or
or h7 then simply Bishop captures on h5
would check so you really don't have a
move here and if you play something like
rook to c2 simply try to hold everything
then you get rook checks King moves and
now Bishop captures and you're gonna
lose the other point as well I have to
replace something and then being a piece
up and having three connected past
points this is clearly winning so yeah
after Bishop captures on f7 and resigned
the game and our great to victory for
the German Grand Master Mathias blue
bomb so far Anand is the highest rated
and of course is the best player a blue
bomb ever defeated but you can check out
more as there is an interview with him
in the link in the description below so
yeah well like I said unfortunately I do
not have any photos but I did prepare
the standings after round six so let's
let's check it out
here we have the standings after round
six that not much has changed with four
points in first place Maxine Varsha
hologram Nikita with YouGov and the
Fabiana Caruana so all the same here
okay Maxine washer is now in first place
to do to maybe some better tie breaks
then Caruana but no you know both of
them still have four points Korean car
stuff
Arjen and Carlson both with three and a
half points so nothing's changed their
blue one did jumpin out to three points
in six places then we have our Kadena
dish in seventh Vishwanath are now in
eighth place with two points same as
holy fun and then we have in last place
kiermaier with one and a half points so
yeah very very interesting tournament so
far and
we're now in the second part of the
tournament everyone played against
everyone and now everyone is gonna play
against everyone one more time only with
different different piece colors so yeah
once again that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Michael
Hildebrand for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully it will another interesting
video have a great weekend